c'est l'heure de la répétition pour frigo et
son maître à seulement vingt mois ce bulldog
anglais élevé à saint roch représente à lui tout
seul l'élite de la race déjà auréolé du titre de
champion de france il va se rendre dimanche au
salon de l'agriculture afin de participer au
concours général agricole pour permettre aux jurés
d'apprécier toutes ses qualités il doit d'abord
savoir rester immobile on le met en statique ce
qu'on appelle en statique pour qui montre bien sa
largeur de mâchoires l'implantation des babines
le laid back ici l'alignement montant néphrons
qu'il examine un peu la taille de la tête sa forme
puis sa poitrine ses aplombs et ensuite le juge
lui va se déplacer autour du chien pour voir
à peu près sa ligne de dos les aplombs arrière
fait c'est lui fuit gora plus d'une centaine
d'autres chiens du type molossoïde pas sûr
qu'il puisse l'emporter et puis le jury pourrait
être influencé par l'actualité en début de mois
la norvège a interdit l'élevage des bouledogues
anglais la sélection aurait été trop loin créant
aux animaux des difficultés respiratoires pour
notre éleveur cette participation parisienne est
donc aussi un acte militant on veut montrer au
grand public le bulldog anglais c'est un chien
qui peut être en parfaite santé comme n'importe
quel autre race de chien que c'est un chien qui
peut courir sauter faire des randonnées évidemment
par des grandes randonnées mais contrairement à ce
qu'on dit un chien qui peut se balader avec vous
une heure ou deux à un rythme normal sans être
essoufflée sans avoir à le porter etc etc entre
70 et 80 chiot naissent chaque année dans cet
élevage de saint roch en dépit de son jeune âge
et de son caractère joueur fuego est déjà papa